[Music]
the ultimate goal of the european union
is to replace all animals used in
science
much progress has been made but many of
the solutions that make us live better
and longer
still continue to involve animals we
must all work together
to move away from using animals in
science and testing
an effective way of advancing this is to
better understand
where when how and which animals are
used in europe
allures is the eu's new database on the
use of animals for scientific purposes
it's the most comprehensive repository
on animal use
for scientific purposes in the world
the user-friendly allures is free and
accessible to everyone
whether you're an interested citizen an
ngo a scientist
or a policy maker there is more
information available to you today
than ever before get data on each use of
an animal
and what type of procedures are
performed learn in which areas
animals are still needed for research
and testing and what types of animals
are being used
genetically altered animals are animals
whose genes have been
either genetically engineered to
incorporate a gene
or to inactivate a gene or it can be
nature
itself that have changed a gene so the
benefits
in scientific research of using
genetically altered animals
is that it offers the means of new and
better ways of
understanding preventing and treating
human diseases find out which areas use
the most
animals in which procedures animals can
experience the most suffering
and which legal requirements lead to
animal use
identify where science urgently needs to
develop alternative approaches
determine where to focus r d efforts and
funding
the eu legislation requires that we
minimise any pain or distress to animals
and we can do this in a whole range of
ways
for example we can use anaesthetics we
can use pain relieving drugs
we can design studies so that they cause
the minimum of pain and distress to
animals
and we can of course house them in the
best possible way
so the eu legislation requires that the
severity of procedures
on animals must be reported but what do
we mean by severity
let me give you an example if an animal
receives a new medicine
and has a blood sample taken that would
be a mild level of severity
if that new medicine caused some side
effects
then that might become a moderate
procedure
and if those side effects became really
major
and for an exact for example an animal
died then that would be a severe
procedure
the eu is committed to the protection
and welfare of animals
still used in science all animal
research and testing in europe
must comply with very strict laws no
living animal can be used for scientific
purposes
without prior authorization as soon as
an
alternative non-animal method is
available animal use can no longer be
authorized
the eu legislation protects animals used
for science
in europe by setting out a framework
and minimum standards for regulating the
use of animals in science
this legislation makes the use of
animals in science more transparent
because researchers and member states
must report
how many animals they use each year as
well as the species involved
and the purposes for which these animals
are used
this transparency helps to protect
animals
because we are able to better understand
where more focus needs to be directed
towards the promotion
of animal-free approaches we need this
transparency
because the public have many concerns
around these use of animals they expect
every possible action to be taken to
ultimately end the use of animals
and their suffering let's work together
to care for animals and aim for better
science